tous et bonjour bonjour
alain livory bonjour à tous les
auditeurs et les internautes de matinée
que la première et permettez moi de
profiter de cette occasion pour adresser
tous mes voeux de bonne année à tous les
martiniquais et plus particulièrement au
diamant tinois des vues de bonne santé
de prospérité de courage et de
solidarité
alors eu tous et vous avez 49 ans vous
êtes 48 ans 48 ans 48 ans vous êtes
directeur d'école vous avez été premier
adjoint du maire sortant du diamant
gilbert eustache qui ne se représente
pas de 2008 jusqu'à janvier 2010 est
d'être prises vice président de l'espace
sud
vous êtes donc candidat et vous allez
conduire la liste liyannaj pour le djia
main et vous êtes soutenus par le rdm
c'est bien ça oui oui tout à fait alors
pourquoi vous présentez alors tout
d'abord dire que c'est la présentation
d'une équipe d'un groupe papa d'un homme
le groupe ya neige pour le diamant est
si vrai que nous travaillons depuis deux
ans pour un projet qui sera un véritable
engagement vis-à-vis de la population
donc une équipe un projet et forcément
il faut d'une tête de liste et nous
avons ensemble les collègues ont décidé
de me proposer comme est en tête de
liste
tout simplement par rapport à la
proximité la première des proximités
c'est que j'habite le diamant c'est à
dire que je me réveille et m'endors au
milieu même de cette population là
l'expérience vous l'avez dit
l'expérience n'ont pas professionnel
mais sur la gestion des affaires
publiques puisque je suis vice-président
de l'espace sud depuis une dizaine
d'années en charge du développement
économique puis du développement social
donc je connais les enjeux de
l'intercommunalité de demain pour les
communes
j'ai été effectivement premier adjoint
je suis également vice président de
l'office de tourisme intercommunal quand
on sait que le tourisme est également un
enjeu pour demain et puis j'ai envie de
dire le dernier à tous et l'altruisme
l'altruisme d'une équipe d'élus qui
m'ont accompagné avec qui j'ai milité
pendant un certain nombre d'années
c'est-à-dire servi à la population et
non se servir et nous en avons fait la
démonstration
tu sais que s'est il passé en 2000
1 lors de l'élection de la ctm qui
accepte d'aider des faits qui ont
provoqué votre mise à l'écart l'année
suivante en 2016 et du fait vous vous
retrouvez aujourd'hui dans l'opposition
primaire alors très rapidement puisque
effectivement je suis surtout venu
parler de projet mais très brièvement
nous n'avons pas et je dis nous parce
que ce n'est pas eu de tous est
seulement certain nombre d'élus nous
avons dénoncé un manque de transparence
manque de démocratie un certain
gaspillage nous avons tiré les sonnettes
d'alarmé maintenant nous n'avons pas été
entendus
donc nous avons décidé de quitter le
groupe puisque c'est pas l'engagement
que nous avions pris avec la population
alors vous serez face à l'actuel premier
adjoint rudy du ville qui n'a pas été
tendre avec vous il vous a traité de
mauvais élève d'élèves turbulent de
premier adjoint défaillant pour ne citer
que ces mots bon pour moi c'est un
épiphénomène
j'ai envie de dire c'est un honneur pour
moi puisque effectivement pendant la
moitié de son interview il a parlé de
moi donc c'est un honneur pour moi et je
pense que la légèrement tinois mérite
mieux que ça parce que aujourd'hui ou
ont dénoncé un certain d'une certaine
violence verbale physique
je crois qu'il n'est pas bon point
candidat de venir sur un plateau avec de
tels propos
et pour clôturer j'ai envie de dire
qu'effectivement peut-être qu'il est
très bon élève est pratiquement le
meilleur élève de gilbert eustache
ça démontre qu'il est bien son poulain
son dauphin son héritier puisque c'est
les mêmes méthodes employées le mépris
le dénigrement la violence verbale et
puis pour clôturer puisqu'en tant
qu'éducateur je me permets de le dire je
les ai toujours dit quand on use de la
violence qu'elle soit verbale ou
physique
c'est un petit peu le dernier recours à
l'incompétence dernière minute
quelles sont les grandes lignes de votre
programme qui tourne autour de trois
grands axes
oui alors nous avons défini trois grands
axes le premier axe concerne le
renforcement du lien social par le
renforcement du lien social on entend
mettre en place une politique active en
pour les associations politiques
sociales politiques éducatives
je n'aurai pas le temps de rentrer dans
les détails deuxième axe concerne
l'amélioration du service public rendu à
la population par le biais de finance
and une gestion rigoureuse des finances
mais aussi la propreté de tous les
quartiers
et puis le troisième axe c'est la
construction du diamant de demain donc
voila un petit plus est la grande
attraction du diamant de demain alors je
vais prendre trois à trois grands enjeux
il ya le l'enjeu de du réaménagement du
bourg qui intègre la place des fêtes
et quand je parle de d'aménagement
global du bon il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement il faut
emmener les commerçants à pouvoir
développer leurs activités mais il ne
faut pas oublier non plus qu'il existe
des habitants qui habite sur place donc
une certaine sérénité
ensuite nous avons un plateau sportif
qu'il faut à tout prix qu'on mette en
place pour les jeunes
et puis j'ai envie de dire enfin une
nouvelle école la prochaine école
puisque c'est un dossier que je suis
depuis le début une tous et je vous
remercie
je vous remercie et à bientôt
[Musique]